for
drink
for for
do I don't know what's going on with my
guitar but it something happened and
it's not it's not holding tune it's not
what was the last time we got set
up probably never probably
it do you know a good Lu uh yeah the
tone shop does really good work and
Addison okay
[Music]
welcome
everyone my name is johnine
Horton and I am so glad to welcome you
here to the table and you guys online
glad you're with us I want you to know
that you are not only welcome here but
you are celebrated
here okay we're going to we got a couple
of
announcements if you are interested in
being baptized then we will offer a
baptism class after the service for
those of you who are interested it'll be
on December the 8th December the 15th
and January the 5th it will be a fairly
short class about 20 to 30 minutes the
baptisms will occur during the service
on Sunday January the 12th so sign up
for the class by scanning the QR
code uh tonight after the service We
Gather at the first Sunday hat Creek
Burger Company right off of a Highway 78
so uh I hope to see you all
there all right we have a Christmas
service announcement because of
scheduling challenges we are going to do
our Christmas Eve service here on Sunday
December the 22nd it will be a
familyfriendly service with the kiddos
staying with us the nursery will be
available we'll sing Christmas carols
we'll light candles all the things we
normally do to celebrate this special
season that's December the 22nd for our
special Christmas Eve on not Christmas
Eve
service that's pretty good all right I
want to bring your attention to the
candles that we light they are a sign of
the presence of Christ with us fully
Divine and fully
human and now let us take a deep breath
let us quiet
ourselves and we'll exit the kingdom of
noise and hurry and
productivity and we will enter the
kingdom of silence and Stillness and
simplicity a Sacred
Space a place for prayer worship and
adoration a place to behold Christ the
revelation of God God the heartbeat of
creation allow this unforced rhythm of
Grace to find you to mend your
heart may we all come
home thank you johnine if you guys would
stand up with us we're g to do some
worship to start our service tonight and
I've been thinking a lot about light as
we enter this Advent season and about
how um there's that scripture in John
1 that talks about the light of God
being with us and entering in and um
tonight I hope that whatever Darkness we
may be facing um as it can be found
anywhere you know we all have our
struggles but when we come together in
this space there's safety in our music
and in Our Song where we can believe in
Hope where we can believe that the Light
of Christ is within us and Shining out
of us and we can grab onto that hope and
carry forward together so let's sing
this day for singing tonight and uh
let's enjoy that honesty and that light
that we find in music as we sing
[Music]
Mercy Rising with the rising of the
sun
goodness rushing in and filling up my
lungs your
faithfulness is here and now the
evidence
is all
around I bless your name I give you
praise today is the day for
singing awake awake my soul come on and
praise the Lord today is a day for
singing sing on my
soul
oh my soul
praise the
Lord my
soul today is a day for
singing a new
song is welling up from deep inside of
me oh and there is a new
life Hallelujah I have been redeemed
I've been
red I bless your name I give you praise
today it's a day for
singing Awake My Soul come on and praise
the Lord today is a day for singing sing
all my S
oh my
soul
PR the
Lord my
oh my
soul today is a day for singing today
today today is a day for singing
[Music]
from the mountains to the valley the
desert to the Fountain oh I will praise
you from the morning to the evening as
long as I am breathing today is a day
for singing let's sing that out together
from the valley to the mountain the
desert into the
fountain oh I will praise
you from the morning to the evening as
long as I can Brea today is the day for
singing one more time today today is a
day for
singing I bless your name I give you
praise today is a for
singing wake my soul come on and praise
the Lord today is a day for singing sing
all my
soul my
soul
praise the
Lord
oh my soul
today is a day for
singing oh my soul
oh
my
praise the
[Music]
Lord my
soul today is the day we're
singing today today is a day for singing
more
time today is a day for
[Music]
singing all right that was a fun one I
don't even think we need to dismiss the
kids tonight they're already like yeah
that's our queue we're on our way yall
have fun thank you Risa and
Harper who else is out there Lily and
Brock Lily Brock so grateful for you
guys and Eve thank you thank you glory
we're going to transition into the
prayers of the people so if you guys
would follow along on the screen and uh
say the parts in red aloud with us and
then um take that space in the middle of
this prayer to speak out loud the things
that you're carrying on your heart if
you feel comfortable sometimes the power
of us saying something out loud and
naming it naming our grief or our pain
or our concern
sometimes just in that moment of being
honest and saying it there can be a
little bit of healing a little bit of
relief of of knowing that we're seen of
knowing that we're not alone and that's
why we come together in this space and
offer up this prayer so I encourage you
to take advantage of that
tonight Jesus for this city of saxi
Texas and for every city and community
and all who live in them we pray to you
for The Good Earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it we pray to you for the old
and the sick for the Widow and the
orphan for the injured and suffering we
pray to you for the poor and the
oppressed the unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and all who
remember and care for them we pray to
you for the vulnerable the marginalized
and those unjustly targeted for their
gender sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss and loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to you
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light healing and
hope peace and a deep sense of your
presence amen
[Music]
I'm caught up in your
presence I just want to sit here at your
feet I'm caught up in this
holy
moment I never want to leave
oh I'm not here for
blessings Jesus you don't owe me
anything more than
anything that you can
do I just want you
[Music]
and I'm
sorry when I've just gone through the
MS I'm
sorry when I just sing another song take
me back to where we
started I open up my
heart you
I'm
sorry when I've come with my
agenda I'm
sorry when I forgot that you're enough
take me back to where we
started I open up my
heart to
[Music]
you I'm caught up in your Pres
I just want to sit here at your
feet I'm caught up in this
holy
moment and never want to
[Music]
leave oh I'm not here for blessing
Jesus you don't owe me
anything more than
anything that you can
do I just want
[Music]
you I just want you and nothing else
and nothing
else nothing else will
do not just want you and nothing
else and nothing
else nothing else will
do I just want
you and nothing
else and nothing else
[Music]
nothing else will
do I just want
you and nothing
else and nothing else
Jesus nothing else will
[Music]
do
W wo
[Music]
[Applause]
now I'm caught up in your
[Music]
presence now just want to sit here at
your
feet I'm caught up in this
holy
moment I never want to
[Music]
leave oh I'm not here for
blessing Jesus you don't know me
anything more than
anything that you can
do I just want you
[Music]
in the beginning was the
word and the Word was with God and the
Word was
God he was with God in the beginning
through him all things were
made without him nothing was made that
has been made in him was
life and that life
was the light of
men the light shines in the
darkness and the Darkness does not
overcome
[Music]
it oh my words fall
short I've got nothing new
how could I
express all my
gratitude I could sing these
songs as I often
do with every song must
end and you never do
so I throw up my hands and praise you
again and
[Music]
again cuz all that I have is
aelu
hallelu and I know it's not much I've
nothing else fit for the
king except for a heart singing
hu
[Music]
Hallelujah I've got one response
I've got just one
[Music]
move with my arms stretched
wide I will worship
you oh so I throw up my hands and praise
you again and
again cuz all that I have is a huah
[Music]
Hallelujah and I know it's not much I'm
nothing else before the
king except for a heart singing
[Music]
Hallelujah huj
oh come on my soul oh don't you get shy
on me lift up your song cuz you've got a
lion inside of those longs get up and
praise the
Lord oh come on my soul oh don't you get
shy on me lift up your soul you got L
inside of
those get up and praise the
Lord oh come on my soul oh don't you get
shy on me lift up your soul cuz you got
a lion inside of
those up and praise the
Lord come on my soul come on my soul
don't you get sh on me lift up your soul
cuz you've got a lion inside of
those get I
praise the Lord
[Applause]
[Music]
name
forever so I throw up my hands praise
you again and
again cuz all that I have is a
Hallelujah
[Music]
Hallelujah and now know it's not much
have nothing else Fit For A
King except for a heart
singing
hallelu Hallelujah
[Music]
thank you God for this moment in this
space where we're able to come before
you in
honesty with a Hallelujah of praise and
thanksgiving and
gratitude and also with a Hallelujah
sometimes that is
broken and all that we have left is just
to sit at your feet and trust that you
are still good trust that you are with
us
[Music]
Emmanuel trust that your light will
continue to guide
us God would we feel its warmth inside
our souls
tonight the Light of
Christ
present near
steadfast
holy and would it help us to see things
through your
eyes with
hope with
[Music]
faith where we believe even sometimes
when we cannot
[Music]
see would you lead us forward this
season
with your love and your light in Jesus
name
amen all right you guys are welcome to
sit down but would you turn to the
people around you as you do and welcome
them say
hello oh Grace and peace peace it is so
good to be with you all uh to welcome
you into this space my name is Brett uh
pronounce he him and yeah it's a joy a
joy to be with you and as always that
includes those joining us online y'all
are not forgotten love you lots and uh
especially anyone here tonight who is
new uh thanks for being Among Us I know
it can well there can just be a lot of
feelings coming into church for the
first time or second time or you know if
it's been a while and um yeah so I hope
you I don't know I hope you find like a
a god of
love you know Christ of compassion
community of uh welcome here at the
table so um tonight we are into a a new
season in the the church calendar if
you've been around the table a while you
know that um we kind of jump on and off
the church calendar at least for when
it's the things you know Advent and uh
lent and Easter and you know all that
we'll kind of jump on the on the
calendar and and I like there's a sense
of connectedness with the broader Church
you know especially a community like
ours I think at times we can feel a
little isolated to put it mildly so I
think it's good to kind of you know
where we can it's like a VIN diagram you
know I mean and we're like come on we
you know it's like uh there's I don't
remember who said this but it was
actually a different religious tradition
talking about Christians he said even if
you are not for us we are for you and uh
I kind of think of that in verse like
when we join the Church calendar and you
know it's like even if you're not for us
we are for you you know and we are for
Christ and we are part of the the
broader church and uh so this is the
season of Advent and for those
unfamiliar um the the word Advent comes
from the Latin adventus um which means
arrival so in essence Advent it's not
exactly the celebration of Christmas per
se uh it's really it's the season Before
Christmas right so it's the season of
kind of heart and mind uh like
preparation for the arrival of Christ in
the world it's kind of akin to like how
lint precedes Easter you know so lint is
not the celebration of Easter quite the
opposite right it's actually a season
kind of a fasting and again preparation
of the the soul and the uh the body for
this kind of reception of of God in the
world and so um this really isn't so
it's it's kind of interesting because
it's it's kind of a celebratory season
but sort of not CU again in a way it's
it's that preparation thing for the big
celebration that is you know Christmas
Eve and um all that to come so um with
that in mind the title of my message
tonight is thinking and
drinking and uh one of the
reasons I I do enjoy jumping on the
church calendar is I also get to follow
What's called the lectionary like
prescribed readings so there's like four
usually readings um and you kind of get
to choose which of the four but it's you
know that's your only options as the
preacher it's like one of those four and
I like it because kind of forces me into
texts that maybe I don't know either
sometimes they're more obscure ones that
I would like I would never think to
preach on that or sometimes it's ones
that I'm like that's a little weird you
know and then I got to kind of figure
out what to do with it and so um this is
one of those so here is our Gospel
reading for today this is Luke 21 uh
verses
25-36 this is Jesus speaking he says
there will be signs in the sun moon and
stars on the Earth Nations will be in
anguish and perplexity at the Roaring
and tossing of the sea people will faint
from Terror apprehensive of what is
coming on the world for the heavenly
bodies will be shaken at that time they
will see the son of man coming in a
cloud with power and great Glory when
these things begin to take place stand
up and lift up your heads because your
Redemption is Drawing Near he told him
this Parable look at the Fig tree and
all the trees when they sprout leaves
you can see for yourselves and know
summer is near even so when you see
these things happening you know that the
kingdom of God is near truly I tell you
this generation will certainly not pass
away until all these things have
happened Heaven and Earth will pass away
but my words will never pass away be
careful or your hearts will be weighed
down with carousing and drunkenness and
the anxieties of life and that day will
close on you suddenly like a trap for it
will come on all those who live on the
face of the whole earth be always on the
watch and pray pray that you may be able
to escape all that is about to happen
and that you may be able to stand before
the son of
man Merry
Christmas okay it's Advent marry you
know you can see where this is sort of
where it's not quite the christmy themes
you know I mean um next week we'll be
into a passage where it's John the
Baptist and again it's a very you know
repent and that's we might be confused
because we're thinking like what
Christmas the baby and the manger and
what is this but actually a lot of
Advent passages are very kind of John
the Baptist prepare the way of the Lord
you know and uh kind of repent and and
and even a lot of passages like this
about the sort of second coming of
Christ in all that so uh okay so what's
going on in this text uh you know based
on passages like this one and others
found all throughout the New Testament
thinking of um Book of Revelation in
particular um so early Christians had
this this um kind of expectation of a
very imminent second coming of Christ in
other words they thought he would return
in glory to judge the living and the
dead soon and very soon you know any day
now and uh that you know that didn't
happen and so as that and I shouldn't
even say as that was delayed um CU even
pretty quickly
you see a kind of different
interpretations in the Church of
passages like this one um now what we'll
kind of get into in a moment is um well
I can just name it so um because of
that the well you get this idea right of
of the soon return of Christ
and other certain Christians start to
kind of question like hm how are we
interpreting this how are we
understanding this might there be like a
little bit of a different approach to
that um so okay so what is this like
different approach um it's an approach
to what's known as eschatology or sort
of in things that realizes a that much
of what we read as very futuristic you
know so when we hear a text like this as
kind of modern Christians and even many
of us not all but kind of H from the
Evangelical kind of wing of the chur
church at least in our past uh what
we're kind of hearing is you know Book
of Revelation sort of end of days kind
of stuff um
however actually likely a lot of the
this passage referred to um the fall of
Jerusalem in 70 AD which is why you'll
notice there in verse 32 Jesus says I
tell you this generation shall not pass
away until these things take you know
it's like wait what this generation how
how long are these people living you
know um which kind of makes sense if it
was the fall of Jerusalem because that's
70 AD right so about 40ish years or so
after um Christ's resurrection and
Ascension um and then also you get a
kind of emphasis in this other kind of
way of interpreting these passages that
rather than kind of
emphasizing a very the future like the
very futuristic notion that you Jesus
will one day return and bring the world
to a close and here's the key and then
and only then will the soul kind of find
its home in
God uh what what you get is more of an
emphasis on beginning to realize that
Union here and now today so while
retaining the idea that Christ will come
again but without trying to get too into
the details and the you know um kind of
guessing on timelines and and all of
that and so um what what happens here is
is passages like this then become um
much more personal and communal and
present by present I mean like here and
now so in essence you might say that
rather than you know the apocalypse will
come at at the end of days and you know
all that the idea becomes a little bit
more um a apocalypse can and does befall
any of
us as we
surrender our own little egos to God and
find ourselves becoming in christed
taking on the very heart and mind of
Christ and in essence very like
saturated with the very presence of God
God through the
spirit and you can already kind of see
this happening in for example the Gospel
of John so we just read the Gospel of
Luke uh the Gospel of John is it's
really it's kind of unique you know
there's he doesn't include almost any of
these like little sayings or passages
like we just read in Luke instead John
is very much about people
experiencing kind of the you might say
the return of Christ in their own heart
and Minds now
today and in essence he wants us to walk
in the light
now so this is a shift I think really
that honestly the broader kind of
Christianity could um really benefit
from since our reading of these texts as
pointing to some kind of future
apocalyptic you know moment um has
tended to create a
theology where people believe the world
needs to get worse and worse in worse in
order for Jesus to come back and so what
happens is you get this kind of
justification of like Wars like
Wars good you know oh excellent this is
just all according to plan you know and
it's like oh no you know or
environmental degradation who cares you
know it's all going to burn anyway you
know this becomes this sort of strange
Glee over tragedy and pain and you know
why because we think oh that's hastening
the day it's hastening it's hastening
the day you
um so so needless to say um and I'll
probably do if it'll be a series at
least future messages to kind of unpack
this this more um but I do think we need
a different a little bit different way
of approaching passages like this again
not in a way that says Jesus he ain't
coming back you know not not that but in
a way that kind of says you know what
Christ I mean what does the second
coming of Christ even mean I don't know
I would try to give a lot of words to
that you know there's a lot of things
like what are we talking about when we
talk about that I don't know you know I
mean in the sense of theology language
to talk it's sort of like when people
try to talk about heaven you know it's
sort of like oh just stop you know like
how are you supposed to it just starts
sounding cartoonish and silly you know I
mean like even images some from
Revelation he's going to come back
riding a horse a white horse you know I
mean which again I think is symbolic but
we take it all very literally and then
it becomes this sort of cartoonish
scenario you know he's like howdy I'm
here you know it's just like what is
going on um all that to say we need
fresh Insight you know fresh kind of
thinking on this so um okay so with that
in mind what I want to do is kind of
take that a little bit different
approach and start to apply it to this
this passage here because I think it
really that this beautifully I think
aligns with this Advent season um right
where the question becomes not simply
you know was Christ born but but really
um will he be born in us today right is
the question is is the spirit of Christ
arriving in our own heart and mind uh
are we being transfigured are we putting
on the mind of Christ as Paul says are
we being transformed by that renewing of
our mind because again as I kind of
survey the broader Christian landscape
what I see are so many Christians out
absolutely obsessed with so-called end
times
prophecy and like they're trying to kind
of discern you know the Tea Leaves of
the future and yet they don't seem so
interested in the arrival of Christ
through the spirit
today in their own heart and mind in
life right it's like that that's what
it's about and that honestly like that's
why I'm a Christian and that's what I'm
interested in is that kind of
transfiguration of of people so okay so
with that in mind I want us to kind of
interpret the ending of our reading from
the Gospel of Luke with this this
different approach this more personal
communal um kind of present uh
understanding so let me kind of frame it
all up with this big idea tonight for
the spirit of Christ to be born in us
this Advent we must remain
watchful alert awake
aware so in our in our text Jesus says
in verse 36 be always on the
watch be always on the watch now with a
more
futuristic uh eschatology right in mind
what that means is be on the lookout for
the return of Jesus um at the end of all
things right however as we start to
shift our View to a more personal
communal present reading um suddenly I I
don't have to wait
around for God to come close to me um I
don't have to wait around for even a
sense of Union and connectedness with
God right I can begin to enter that
now but the question is
how and I think the answer is I must be
on the watch early in verse 34 Jesus
said be careful the Greek there is
literally like take heed pay attention
be alert wake up right be careful or
what will happen or your hearts I love
this language will be weighed
down with carousing drunkenness and the
anxieties of life it's a powerful image
isn't it we might say that it's so easy
to get weighed
down at precisely the very moment God is
inviting me to do what to wake up it's
so easy to get weighed down right when
God's like wake up wake up I'm here I'm
present I'm active I'm moving in your
life like I'm inviting you into the more
I want to arrive not just at the end of
all things whatever exactly that means
and how that will look I don't know you
know but like today now here in life
right that that's what it's about so now
we might ask though like what does it
mean though to be kind of weighed down
what does that that look like um I was
reflecting on that in light of a there
was a video I linked to a week or two
ago in my e-letter um this talk by David
Kates on um the kind of trauma and
presence and the body and all this and I
I really I loved it that was fantastic
and um so I'm kind of drawing this is an
exact quote of David Kates but I want us
to maybe think of way down
in this way we might say I am weighed
down when my body is in one place but my
mind is in
another um I really like that way of
thinking about it I I'm weighed down
when my body is here but my mind is here
which by the way is how we live like 99%
of our lives at least if you're anything
like me you know just this is what
happens to us right in other words for
Christ is born in us the presence of God
can only fill us when there is a certain
congruence and an alignment a a presence
when we are here like even now I have to
ask like are you
here you here because it's so easy right
to just sort of like we're here I mean
each of you are sitting here but where's
your mind you know I don't say that in
like a shamey way I mean this happens to
all of us you know we're just we're here
but we're not here we're kind of here
but also got oh God it's Monday tomorrow
you know I me like it's this weird
dynamic um right so weigh being weighed
down is the opposite of being here
attuned awake we get lost in thought
lost in the chatter of the mind we're
just we're checked out you know unaware
asleep so to speak I appreciate here
that Jesus name's both being drunk and
the anxieties of Life uh we'll speak to
anxiety that example first uh so what is
the anxieties of life I think of this as
like the death of
awareness of the presence of God like
the awareness of my own myself my body
the other wonderful people here the
spirit who's here right it's sort of
it's the death of that by like a
thousand paper cuts you know like in
essence we just feel we have a thousand
things to do a thousand things to track
a thousand things to ruminate
on and so what happens like the vast
majority of our day is kind of spent in
this strange uh
disassociated
space where again body is doing one
thing mind is endlessly on past and
future and really at best the mind's in
kind of a neutral kind of nonsense you
know I mean just sort of weird whatever
that's at best at worst it's
incredibly negative in nature um like I
don't know about you but if my mind's
just wandering I'm usually I'm just
churning on problems you know what I
mean I'm problem solving problems like
either stuff in the past I'm like why
why did that happen why this how did I
say that or oh God I shouldn't you know
I mean or future what's to come
what's you know just
constantly problem solving and uh like
in essence have you ever this I have
anxiety so um I mean all humans do but
you know I mean have kind of mild to
moderate anxiety as a thing it's all I
wake up in the morning I'm just laying
in bed and I can I know right away how
the days you know like in terms of heads
space how I'm going to be like immediate
you know and I'll be laying there and
like in essence I'm never laying there
thinking like
gratitude lists you know what I mean
like it's never like hey BR what are you
doing oh sorry I was just lost in
thought I was just counting my blessing
you know like of course not no it's
always like hey wake up come back you
know I'm like oh sorry I've been off in
land churning through you know all these
problems that are never going to happen
um yeah there's a uh there's a a teacher
spiritual teacher whose work I
appreciate um at C toly and he says his
line is I kind of took my title my
message a little bit from Inspire by
this line he says can't stop drinking
can't stop thinking which it seems to me
is just the most perfect summary of Luke
21:34 right the Mind weighs us down with
the anxieties of Life thinking thinking
thinking thinking think thinking
thinking and in response we can't stop
drinking drinking drinking drinking
drinking right or or in essence in
numbing ourselves right numbing
ourselves checking out disassociating
trying to uh escape to releve our pain
like a about a year ago or so a little
less um someone visited the table and
they uh they didn't like my they didn't
like my
sermon and but that's okay you know I
know sometimes yall don't like my that's
fine um but then they sent me an email
about it and uh and this is just a
visitor you know I mean it was like
their first time and they so I think
maybe they felt a little Freer you know
they're like I'll never see this guy
again whatever and so they kind of just
let me have it I mean it was honestly it
was like I've received some emails you
know I mean in my day um had people like
walk out of sermons and stuff um mainly
at the other church but um you can yeah
so this one it was it was just it was
tough it was it was tough and uh one of
the lines that kind of got me was like I
just wouldn't feel safe my me and my
family just wouldn't feel safe at a
church where the preacher just giving
his thoughts instead of Holy Scripture
you know and didn't like how I was
interpreting things you know what I mean
and so I finally so fast forward like
eight
months and I'm out on my side job you
know
scooping and I find myself and I'm
obsessed with this
email like I'm just churning on it and
I'm just scooping like and I'm arguing
you know it's like Point Counterpoint
Counterpoint to the Counterpoint you
know I mean and freaking I don't even
care that you don't like you know I mean
just this I'm just like literally was
like about halfway through the yard I
realized what's happening I'm like deep
breaths you know like it's okay let it
go let it go let it you know I I can't I
just back to it within 5 Seconds just
turn it like that house next house next
house next it's just like oh my gosh you
know like this
is I mean I don't know I'm assuming I'm
not alone in this sort of thing you know
we just we get we get stuck right what
was happening there was a perfect
example body and one
place mind somewhere else or even take
Church uh for example I I love you know
our times of worship and and such um and
that find that so centering and
grounding each week to sing and express
love for God and and do that kind of
communally and all that but if you're
anything like me you'll kind of be there
in the moment and then suddenly find
your mind like why do the Cowboys have
to suck so bad you know
or what if one of these things fell like
these light fixtures someone would die
you know or what like it's like you're
again body is in one place you're doing
one thing and then all of a sudden here
sorry I've added to your anxieties of
Life some of you can maybe scoot if you
need to move a seat or two that's fine
um I'm sure they're very secure don't
worry we've never had one fall
everything's
great I know I've lost you all maybe I
shouldn't have done that example
everyone
just um I should also mention that again
kind of drawing on David Kate's work the
more on unprocessed trauma that you have
in your life the more disassociated
you'll be tempted to
be right because the the the present in
the the mind um can be a difficult kind
of place to be you know and so there's
this temptation to kind of flee to run
to check out and uh and to use you know
substances to kind of um slip below
thought you might say you know kind of
like ah just check out which brings us
to the carousing and drunkenness
language which in the Greek carousing is
basically just like a variant of another
term for drinking so it's like drinking
and drunken or something you know um now
to be clear J he's not saying I don't
think like if you have a drink that's a
sin you know clearly it's talking about
drinking to excess here um
and and really kind of naming when we're
in that kind of mode you know um if we
if we look kind of under the hood of our
life I think we often um notice that
we're kind of a we're using that to
avoid you know avoiding reality avoiding
feelings to use that psychological
language again we're we're
disassociating and of course alcohol
drugs other things you that's a very
common popular way of of dealing kind of
dealing with mental health struggles you
know it's self-medicating
um but I think if there's probably the
one I think they've been eclipsed though
by all of the amazing forms of
entertainment that we now have we might
even call it the drug of entertainment
like right in essence when I'm scrolling
on YouTube or binging Netflix or playing
games on my phone you or whatever what
am I doing it's that
disconnect you know I'm bringing in that
disconnect bodies in one place Minds
kind of in another mother in fact I've
noticed when I'm working I have this
instinctual habit where like when I
receive a difficult email or a difficult
text you know that kind of Springs
feelings in me I notice like almost
instinctually I'll I'll be on a social
media app you ever done this yourself
like where you it's sort of like the
thing comes in oh difficult conversation
oh difficult feelings run run run away
you know I mean it's this this strange
kind of
Disconnect so so what's the antidote to
all this
um this can't stop drinking can't stop
thinking problem I think the antidote is
um in light of Jesus teaching here I
think it's awareness I think it's
presence presence presence Be watchful
be alert wake up wake up wake up be here
be here we must come home to ourselves
in our bodies as the spiritual teacher
lot Kelly says learn to return train to
remain learn to return train to remain I
think that's a beautiful kind of encaps
encapsulation of like a life of prayer
it's just learning to come back
here we must remain watchful we must be
where our feet are now you say oh this
is very scary it's hard for me to be you
know present to myself for five minutes
much less all the time you know maybe we
should begin more modestly the first
step we could say into deep awareness in
the presence of God is to Simply notice
notice all the times I'm checking out
that's like a little more modest isn't
it so it's not saying like never check
out again you know it's like oh right
you know uh but instead just start
tuning in noticing huh look what I'm
doing look what I'm doing I'm on the
social medias again um why you know and
it's it's just kind of being awake to
that noticing when I am weighed down
noticing when I am unaware and then
learning to
return so closing just to encourage you
what will begin to happen as you do that
I promise you your entire way of being
in this world will change like your
whole vibe with people you ever been
with someone and you can just sense
their awakeness so to speak they're they
presence to you you know they're really
there not not body in one place mind in
another um they're really there and
that's what can happen to us right just
imagine the type of a friend the partner
the coworker the person you would be if
you were begin to begin to wake up alert
aware of yourself and others imagine
what would happen to your spiritual life
in Vitality if you were awake alert
aware that's the invitation that's the
invitation this Advent season in the
name of the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit
amen so on the night Jesus was
betrayed he had uh one final meal with
his disciples and at that meal he held
up a loaf of bread and then he broke it
and he said this is my body it's broken
for you then he held up a cup of wine he
said this is my blood it's shed for you
whenever you eat this bread whenever you
drink this cup remember me remember me
so for 2,000 years now Christians have
gathered at the table to remember again
to reenter to reground ourselves in the
Christ who is always with us and even as
you we take in like not just around us
but even within um our very
being um so the the kind of the way
we'll participate and take communion
tonight is um we'll just start here at
the front row and we'll go just kind of
row by row we'll form one line right
here in the middle um we practice an
Open Table meaning if you're here
tonight and you'd like to participate
then you're free to do that uh
regardless of you know denomination or
whatever kind of background
um also if you don't want to partake
that's fine too you know there's no no
pressure you should know the red is wine
the white is grape juice and then
finally just um partake whenever you'd
like some folks like to come and kneel
others return to their seats and partake
um you just kind of do that however and
whenever you'd like to so this is the
table not of the
church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you
who've tried to follow you who failed
come come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you and it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the table
[Music]
d
if you guys would like to stand with us
we're going to close out um going back
to that song that we sang earlier called
nothing
else let's just St in that posture of
presence of keeping our mind and our
heart in this space together just as we
finish out this service and and checking
in with what the spirit might be saying
to
[Music]
us and I just want you and nothing
else and nothing
else nothing else will
do I just want you and nothing
else nothing
else nothing else will
do I just want
you nothing
else nothing
else nothing else will
do I just want you and nothing
else nothing else
Jesus nothing else will
[Music]
do nothing
[Applause]
else w
[Music]
I'm caught up in your
presence not just want to sit here at
your
feet I'm caught up in this
ho
moment I never want to
leave oh I'm not here for blessing
Jesus you don't owe me
anything more than anything that you can
do I just want
you more than
anything that you can
do I just just
one
[Music]
you well thank you all so much for being
here this evening if you are new we'd
really love for you to fill out a
visitor's card it's on the little table
as you go out or you can and the QR code
and fill out an online
form also if you'd like to get involved
more here and you'd like to uh get more
relational support and spiritual
connection uh why don't you try one of
our meetup groups there are several of
them they meet on different week nights
we also have other classes that are
shorter term so try to get connected
here uh generosity is a key aspect of a
life of adoration and worship and if
you'd like to call the table your church
home and like to invite you to scan the
QR code and join us in supporting this
work
financially now if you'd like to you can
hold your hands out in a gesture of
receiving or you can just open your
hearts to this
message you are a child of
God you you are a child of
God this is true on your very best day
and it's true on your worst day so as
you go into your week ahead with it's
yet to be determined highs and lows and
everything in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved that you are worthy
that you are a accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact with be
blessed we'll see you next Sunday or
hopefully we'll see you at hat
Creek God in your presence
I just want to sit here at your feet I'm
caught up in this
holy
moment I never want to
[Music]
leave oh I'm not here for
blessing Jesus you don't know me
anything more than anything that you
could
do I just want
you more than
anything that you can do I just
want you
[Music]
don't
have I don't
have I
[Music]